uh-oh so Scott of course is a leader in
the field he's a mentor to many young
people myself included I know you know I
think he's directly responsible for a
lot of the theory of quantum supremacy
and you know today he'll tell us about
next major step for the field which is
trying to find useful applications of
the the quantum supremacy experiment
okay so here's Scott all right well
thank you so much bill and it's great to
be here so shortly before civilization
collapsed a few months ago and we
entered this freak branch of the wave
function that we're now in Google of
course showed that using their 53 qubit
programmable chip called Sycamore they
could take as input a description of a
quantum circuit call it see and then
they could quickly produce some samples
they call them s1 up to SK from the
output distribution of C now of course
we can't directly test that there from
the output distribution but we can check
for consistency with that hypothesis
using what Google called the linear
cross entropy benchmark or linear xeb
and this is a benchmark that I'll also
be using throughout this talk and what
this simply means is that if you want to
judge you know the fidelity of a sort of
quantum sampling experiment you take
each of the outputs that were produced
s1 up to SK you know each of which in
this case would be a 53 bit string and
then using your classical computer and
brute force you calculate for each one
the ideal probability that the circuit
si would have output S sub I and then
you just sum all of those probabilities
up and then you accept if and only if
that sum exceeds a certain threshold
okay and the threshold has the form of B
times K divided by 2 to the N where here
n is the number of qubits here it's 53
you know for Sycamore K is the number of
samples the number of in-depth
and draws from the distribution in the
case of Google's experiment that was
about 5 million which they were able to
do in just a few minutes because it's
only you know a few tens of microseconds
per sample B is a measure of the
fidelity that basically we would like to
be bounded above 1 and in the case of
the Google experiment they reported a B
value of one point zero zero two so you
know slightly above one okay and so you
know that this might look a little bit
different from what was in Sergio's talk
but it's just a different way of
presenting the same thing okay and so
okay well but what does any of this mean
okay well just to give you a sense for
these numbers you know if we just didn't
have a quantum computer at all and let's
say we just produced a bunch of output
strings s1 up to SK uniformly at random
you know with no knowledge of any
quantum circuit or anything well even
then you would expect the average
probability to be 2 to the minus n they
after all you know this is a
distribution over n bit strings all
right so I add up kind of those by
linearity of expectation I expect the
sum to be about K over 2 to the N so in
other words I expect to achieve a value
B equals one could say ok now what about
with the perfect and noiseless quantum
computer well there it's just a little
calculation it was it was an integral
that uh fortunately despite being a
computer scientist even I remembered how
to do and the you do the integral you
get the value of 2 you know assuming
that as we expect that a random quantum
circuit gives you a sort of Porter
Thomas type of distribution you then
expect the sum to be about two times K
over 2 to the N twice the classical
value now the key point is that we do
not know of any polynomial time
classical algorithm that would spoof
these samples that is that would produce
samples s1 up to SK you know given the
circuit C in a way that we
she've a b-value that was even slightly
bounded above what like one point zero
zero zero zero one for example or even
one plus 2 to the minus n not even that
do we know how to achieve classically
okay now can we prove that there's no
such algorithm well of course we can't
you know we can't even prove that P is
different from P space or you know all
kinds of more basic things than that we
would love to be able to prove that if
there were such an algorithm and the
polynomial hierarchy would collapse but
for reasons that were discussed in the
previous two thoughts we don't know how
to do that either but in a paper a few
years ago with Luigi Chen and in a more
recent paper with a SAM gun we were able
to give some modest complexity theoretic
evidence against such an algorithm
namely we were able to show that if
there were such a classical algorithm
then you would also get a fast classical
algorithm that could estimate certain
you know like like the probability of a
particular output in a random quantum
circuit with a variance that's slightly
better than what the trivial estimator
what did you say and you know we yeah I
don't know that that's impossible but at
any rate it would have some consequence
for sort of our ability to classically
simulate quantum circuits that is not
just about spoofing a sampling problem
okay
so then the question is you know Google
reported B equals one point zero zero
two so you know is this a proof of
quantum supremacy well you know as
everyone knows you know there has been a
debate about that question I mean I
think that it is fair to say you know
you know if you look at Fresco's paper
from 2012 what he meant by quantum
supremacy that you know that it has been
achieved keeping in mind that this is
something that can be achieved and then
unachieved later if you know someone
discovers a better classical algorithm
okay but you know there has been some
dispute you know now the central
drawback of the current sampling
supremacy experiment is that as far as
we know today even just to verify the
samples with a
classical computer takes to to the end
time just like classical spoofing fix
right so there's sort of a cat-and-mouse
game between the two you could say you
know if an your number of qubits is
small enough for verifying well then
maybe it's also small enough for
spoofing to be practical right and yeah
this was sort of that this point was at
the heart of IBM's response paper that
they put out where they tried to rebut
Google's claim where they said look if
we used some ik you know it has two
hundred and fifty petabytes of hard disk
and using that we could just explicitly
store the entire state of the 53 qubit
Sycamore chip to hard disk and thereby
simulated in just a few days it sounds
from Sergio's talk like Johnny Gray's
recent results would give an alternative
way to do that of course this has not
been actually demonstrated yet but you
know what's let's take it that it's
something like that would possibly work
well ok then then you know you could say
there's still a gap in that you know the
quantum computer is producing outputs in
a matter of a few minutes we're you know
verifying them took days you know so we
still have some gap there but of course
we would like to we would like some
experiment you know a some disk sampling
experiment where we could do the
verification efficiently I mean that I
regard as the biggest theoretical open
problem in this little area right now ok
but now having said that you know maybe
you know the most fundamental objection
that people raised to you know the
supremacy experiment and that I had to
answer you know to journalists and on my
blog and elsewhere was well what are
such experiments good for so you know
trying to make a list of what the
sampling based quantum supremacy
experiment is good for well you know it
is good for disproving the people like
Gil kalaiy who said the quantum
computing speed ups were impossible in
our universe that's number one number
two
well it's hard to think of number two no
no I mean you know it's good for device
calibration you know as Sergio talked
about it is good for sort of various you
know internal engineering goals but you
know is it good for any actual
application and you know that has been
you know one of the biggest unknowns in
this area okay so now this leads to an
idea a thought that I had a couple of
years ago which was that well you know
maybe there is something that you can
use this type of sampling experiment for
you know it just generates a bunch of
bits that are mostly random you know and
that sounds pretty useless unless random
bits are actually what you want and then
maybe it could be useful okay so in
particular let's consider the problem of
generating bits that we can show to be
random under some plausible
computational assumptions okay so of
course if we believe quantum mechanics
then it is trivial to generate as many
random bits as you want you know using a
you know all sorts of you know quantum
mechanical you know apparatus or
radioactive decay or whatever you know
you can buy devices online or go to
websites that will claim to generate
quantum mechanical random numbers for
you okay but suppose that we need a
public source of random bits that are
going to be placed on the Internet and
then everyone has to be able to download
and Trust as being really random even
though they don't know you know what
hardware is being used to generated you
know can we do that
okay well so so the the observation I
made was that once you can get a
sampling based supremacy experiment like
Google's to work you know then almost
immediately you can repurpose it for a
sort of protocol in which a classical
Challenger who starts with a small
pseudo random seed would you know
generate some challenges send those
challenges to a quantum computer demand
back responses within a very short time
and then verify those responses at its
leisure and using you know classical
brute force and then if the response is
past the verification then under some
computational assumption you would have
some guarantee that the responses must
have had at least such-and-such entropy
such-and-such mean entropy okay now is
that useful for anything well you know
there are all sorts of applications
where you want a public source of
trusted randomness an example being
proof of state crypto currencies like
the next-generation etherium but it's
the bay okay that would replace the sort
of massive you know a wastage of energy
of Bitcoin but you know something else
but the something else requires a large
public you know trusted randomness
source okay having said that there are
there are a lot of issues in actually
making this practical you know in big
your you know can it be acceptable
secure in practice you know can it be a
spoof you know by a you know with with
sort of reasonable expenditure on the
part of the adversary and of course you
know it has to be compared to all the
alternatives which you know the ideas
for public randomness could range from
using the last digits of the Dow Jones
Industrial Average I don't know if you
want to use that right now maybe it's
too you know erratic but over you know
to using the pattern of granules that
would form on the surface of the Sun
okay there's all sorts of places in the
world where you could look for public
randomness you know this one
to compete against all sorts of other
things so I don't know if it will be
useful in practice but the claim that
I'll make for it is that you know at
least this protocol sort of refutes the
statement that it is obvious that
sampling on disk quantum computers has
zero application to anything ok it
refutes the obvious 'no sub the
inapplicability ok so ok so so what what
is the protocol well basically you know
it involves a classical client which
generates quantum circuits on n qubits
called the circuit c1 up to CT it
generates them pseudo randomly so in a
way that would mimic a truly random
ensemble then at each round little T in
the protocol the client sends the the
most recent circuit a C sub T over to
the quantum computer server and it
demands back a response which we'll call
SMT within a very short time like say a
second ok now in the honest case that
response would simply be a list of K
independent samples from the output
distribution that you get by applying C
sub P to the old 0 initial State and
then measuring in the computational
basis ok then next the client using its
tiny seed randomness picks a few random
iterations and for each of those
iterations it you know just goes and
invest the brute force to calculate the
linear cross-entropy score for those
iterations and make sure that you know
it gets a score that's bounded above 1
like a signature of quantum behavior ok
now if it does if the tests pass then
you get some lower bound from the
analysis on the amount of min entropy
that has to be there in all of the
samples concatenated together under some
computational assumptions you don't know
where the entropy is but you can take
all the samples and you can then feed
them into a known tool a classical
randomness
tractor such as the so-called govt
extractor in order to get out nearly
pure random bits that you could then use
for some cryptographic application okay
now the central point that I wanted to
focus on in the rest of this talk is
kind of the main conceptual point behind
the whole scheme which is why must there
be any entropy whatsoever in the
server's responses that is you know how
do we know that you know the sir even if
the server has to be a quantum computer
it's not a quantum computer that just
answers each challenge in a secretly
deterministic way all right well I want
to give you some sense for how the
argument gets so what we do is we
suppose to the contrary that there is
some function s you know in bqp so you
know efficiently computable by a quantum
computer such that his samples return s
you know is just equal to f of c it's
just a function of the circuit that it's
given okay you know we want to show that
if a secret deterministic such function
existed then this would imply some
strange computational powers on the part
of somebody okay so you know like in all
complexity theory we have to start from
some problem that we're assuming to be
hard so I'm going to give you a somewhat
strange problem which I call long list
quantum supremacy verification ll qsv it
needs a better name but this is the
fouling problem you are given Oracle
access or if you like random access to a
gigantic list of ramp actually random
quantum circuits ac1 up the CM okay and
by by gigantic I mean M is exponentially
large okay like it's you know 10 to the
N power or something you're also given a
bunch of n bit strings s 1 up to SM and
being a number of qubits of each circuit
ok now you're asked to distinguish two
cases case one is that these each s sub
I was say
you just uniformly random case to is
that each SF I was sample from the
output distribution of the corresponding
C's of us okay was that clear we want to
distinguish these two cases so you know
and I want you to think of you know this
problem yet it seems pretty hard I mean
you could do it in sharpie or something
but it seems hard even if you had a
quantum computer that could access this
began of Oracle okay well I'm going to
stick my neck out a little bit further
you know conjecture that they're sort of
know am protocol for this problem and
the the key claim is that sorry
if there were a quantum computer that
could pass the linear cross entropy test
in a secretly deterministic way then
there would be a QC AM protocol for ll
qsv okay we're here QC a.m. means click
quantum classical Merlin Arthur
so it just AM with a classical Merlin
and a quantum Arthur who can verify the
response okay so now why would we get
such a QC AM protocol well you know
intuitively the whole problem just boils
down to approximate counting in other
words we have this exponentially long
list of circuits and purported samples
from the circuits and now you know it's
effaces if we can just estimate how many
eyes are there in our gigantic list such
that F of C sub I equals S sub ah okay
so we know we're trying to you know that
this is an exponentially small subset
but you know with the help of a Merlin
we could do approximate counting to try
to lower bound the size of this subset
figure out you know are there sort of
more circuits than we would expect in
the purely random case for which you
know the sample that is there is
actually what the function f produces
when you want it on that circuit okay so
you know so to the standard approximate
counting trick of you know goldwasser
scepter or
stockmeyer
so on you know Arthur would just send
Merlin a random ash function a G and as
demand that Merlin sent back in index I
such that F of C sub I equals SFI and
also I hash is to some particular value
like the hole 0 1 under that hash
function G okay so you can do
approximate counting to sort of check
that you're in the yes case the case of
valid sampling now as an observation
notice that if our circuits C sub I
we're all classical then there actually
would be an AM protocol to solve this
problem right because a classical
circuit has the property of being
reproducible you know you can always
just get the same output over and over
by rerunning it with the same input
condition even if it has randomness you
can just fix the random bits that it
uses okay so this is one way of
understanding why quantum computation is
actually important for this argument and
for this randomness protocol more
generally okay now the more technical
part is how do you show that in each
round of this protocol you're not just
getting let say one random bit or 0.1
random bits or you know some tiny amount
of randomness but you're actually
getting omega of n random bits so an
amount that scales like the number of
qubits in your circuit well the way we
do that we have to design a rather more
complicated AM protocol say but we say
suppose you had a bqp machine called M
that sampled asked that list of samples
from a probability distribution that had
two properties of one it put a large
mass like at least Q on samples that
passed the linear cross-entropy fest and
two it put a large mass like at least P
on samples that have a big weight so
like they're sort of heavy you know
they're they're not good in terms of min
entropy they've got like min entropy of
only H they've got probability of 2 to
the minus H or they H is less than it
okay and then also
poses B and P and Q are big enough then
there is an AM protocol for this ll qsv
problem with a quantum verifier running
in time about 2 to the H over 2 and also
with a small advice strip ok the
intuition for this is that merlin is
going to pleat arthur to those circuits
C sub I for which that quantum algorithm
M outputs this string a sub I with a
large probability of probability at
least 2 to the minus H and then knowing
those circuits Arthur can then use
grover search to check Merlin's claims
which will tell you know amplitude
amplification will take about 2 to the H
over 2 time in that case okay now when
you design this QC AM protocol the
central difficulty in the sense is that
Mervyn is trying to convince Arthur of
statements like you know the algorithm M
on the circuit C sub I outputs the
string s sub I with probability at least
2 to the minus H ok well the problem is
by itself that's just not going to work
because you know what if that
probability was right near the threshold
of 2 to the minus H right you can't you
know exactly calculate the probability
ok so you say all right so allow some
leeway let's say that merlion only needs
to convince Arthur that the probability
is at least 1 minus epsilon over 2 to
the H but then the problem is as soon as
you allow that leeway well then you know
that could destroy the soundness because
maybe there were vastly more circuits
they were where you know C sub I outputs
si by with probability 1 minus Epsilon
you know over 2 to the H so then you
know and once you've lowered the bar to
that well then a cheating Merlin could
sneak in 1 minus 2 Epsilon you know
acceptors and so on so you know you
would seem to get an infinite regress so
you need some definite place to stick
your threshold where you'll get a good
gap between completeness and soundness
and in some sense the main thing that I
had to show in the theoretical analysis
is that there is such a threshold
so basically that there is going to be
some epsilon less than a half such that
there's a large gap between you know how
well mer you know between completeness
and soundness so how well Merlin can do
you know getting you to accept the 1
minus epsilon over 2 to the H in the yes
case and how well he could do getting
you to accept slightly less probable
than that output strings in the no case
and then once you know that epsilon you
can hardwire it in as part of the advice
it has a tiny bit of advice to the am
protocol okay so you know when you work
out all the parameters to try to get the
rate of randomness generation from this
scheme basically what you get is you get
you know so l which is some hardness
parameter which would be at most n over
2 where n is the number of qubits in
your quantum computer and then times
some quantity which is looks like B
times Q minus 1 divided by B minus 1
where B is that threshold parameter for
the linear cross entropy test and Q is
the observed success probability of the
quantum computer and actually passing
the linear cross entropy okay so
basically you know you need B times Q to
be larger than 1 to have any you know
for this protocol to work at all get any
rate of random bit generation and this
kind of determines you know your
physical hardware requirements basically
as your hardware is noisier then you
need you know then that's going to lower
your success probability Q then to get B
times Q greater than 1 then you need a
larger B okay but then you know if I set
the threshold higher that's going to
decrease my success probability even
more you know so that sounds really bad
the escape route is that I can set B to
be just slightly larger than 1 in
particular to about 1 plus Delta where
Delta is the quantum computers fidelity
and then I can take a large number of
samples so I'll ask for like K samples
where K is like 1 over Delta squared and
then I appeal to the law of large
numbers so not surprisingly the noisier
my quantum
computer some more samples I need in
order to get the same amount of entropy
out okay and there are a few remaining
parts of the analysis like you have to
show that generating the Sam the
challenge circuit pseudo randomly is
okay under some further hardness
assumption you need to show the hardest
part is you need to show that the
entropy actually accumulates from one
round of the circuit to the other that
there's not some weird conspiratorial
correlations that would keep the entropy
from growing for that I use the
combinatorial that Madhu Tyrone pellet
among lots of other ingredients okay now
let me just tell you what is I think is
the biggest challenge for this protocol
for really making it useful the biggest
challenge well it's something I
mentioned before that is to make the
find a way to make the verification
efficient that is that it can be done in
time polynomial and n rather than 2 to
the N you know the trouble is that until
one does that there will always be a
cat-and-mouse game between the verifier
and the scooper so you know the likely
if the verification time in the spoofing
time or both of order 2 to the N right
then you're you're limited to let's say
60 cubits or what if 65 qubits whatever
and then you know maybe spoofing could
be done now what gives some hope is that
the verification as I said needs to be
done only for only a tiny random sample
of the round so it needs to be done only
very very occasionally and at the
verifiers leisure whereas the spoofing
to be successful would have to have to
happen over and over and over again so
if you had a quantum computer that could
do one round per second well then the
spoofing with your classical computer
would also have to happen once per
second ok but on the other hand the
super could always buy more hardware
they could paralyze maybe they could
even spend you know billions of dollars
to buy you know I don't know however
many petabytes of RAM to do you know
like like for this business gene but in
RAM right so you know you're always kind
of worried about that kind of thing ok
now in
well we know that this kind of problem
can be solved because of the beautiful
protocol from a couple years ago by a
broker ski Christiano mahadeva dick and
maserati so they gave a completely
different scheme for generating
certified random bits with a quantum
computer their scheme has efficient
verification it is based on cryptography
based on lwe okay unfortunately I think
it remains unclear whether that scheme
can be practical in the disk era so the
central problem if you like is can we
get efficient verification and mistiness
at the same time okay that's you know a
question for certified randomness
schemes in particular it's also a
question for just any application of
NIST quantum computers you know more
generally ok there are lots of other
interesting challenges but can one get
more and more certified randomness by
reusing the same circuit over and over
that would make the protocol much more
efficient could we get soundness under
less boutique complexity assumptions can
we get soundness even against the
bursaries that are in handled with the
quantum computer and how are there good
protocols to solve the problem of well
why should anybody else trust the
verifier and you know why should they
trust the secret seed that is being used
by the verifier to generate the
challenges or indeed of the copy large
verification computations that the
verifier has to do so let me stop there
and thanks a lot for your attention
great and I'm sorry we've run into
overtime but I am happy to take any
questions